This episode is sponsored by Blinkist.
Blinkist puts all of the need to know information
from thousands of nonfiction books and condenses
them down into just 15 minutes and you can
go to blinkist.com/microcosmos to learn more.
There are plenty of ways to get food in the
microcosmos, but the cilia-driven vortex seems
particularly charming.
The microbes who use this method can graze
in place if they want to, stirring up whirls
and whirls and whirls of water to draw food
in towards them.
Rotifers, like this philodina here, use the
crown of cilia around their head to create
that movement in the water and cycle food
like algae into closer proximity.
But watch carefully: if you tap the slide
and momentarily shock the rotifer into curling
inward, it’ll stop juggling its algae meal.
And more strikingly, the algae itself immediately
stops moving.
Any additional movement you see in the algae
is because the rotifer’s movements are displacing
the water.
When the rotifer’s cilia were in motion,
the algae looked like they were caught up
in a fast-moving whirlpool.
Now, it’s almost like they’re stuck in
molasses.
And in a way, they kind of are.
It is not that the algae are actually in molasses.
Like all our other samples, they’re living
it up in good old H20.
And of course to us, liquid water is a flowing
thing.
We can swim through it, jump into it, run
our hands through it, gather samples for this
show from it--all with relative ease.
But for microbes, water isn’t like that.
It’s like a syrup.
And while life in syrup sounds whimsical,
the mechanics and math that explains it is
much less so.
And thus we are going to give you just a very
broad idea of what’s going on here.
Warning, fluid dynamics ahead.
The way things move in a fluid is an extremely
complex, dynamic thing that’s characterized
and defined in many different ways.
But the most useful description for us is
what’s called the Reynolds number, which
tells us whether or not the movement we’re
interested in is dominated by inertia or viscosity.
When the Reynolds number is higher, the inertial
forces dominate, which means that an object
or fluid that is gliding is more likely to
keep on gliding.
And when the Reynolds number is lower, the
viscous forces dominate, and that brings things
to a halt.
If we’re comparing things moving in water,
then one of the most useful things to note
is that an organism’s Reynolds number will
generally increase with its size.
A person swimming in water might have a Reynolds
number that’s on the order of 10,000, which
lets us glide a little between each stroke.
A blue whale  might be somewhere
on the order of 100 million, which lets it
travel quite far with just a flap of its tail.
Bacteria, by comparison, they’re working
with a Reynolds number that’s more on the
order of 0.00001.
And where a whale or a person can travel multiple
body lengths depending on how we generate
power, a bacteria that’s been pushed by
something else will only travel about a tenth
of the diameter of a hydrogen atom before
coming to a stop.
That is not far.
So for the microcosmos, water is not the lovely
flowing thing that we know and love.
It’s thick and syrupy, and it should be
a challenge to move through.
But as you may have noticed, many of these
microbes are still plenty fast.
Sometimes we get questions about whether we’ve
sped up the footage, and the answer is that
unless we’ve otherwise noted any changes
in speed, that is the real-time speed of these
organisms.
Even in this clip, the various flagellates
and ciliates are moving quite fast--and that’s
after we slowed down the footage 500%.
So like…how?
How can they move so fast in syrup?
We went into more detail about how single-celled
eukaryotes do this many episodes ago.
Some use cilia, others use flagella.
And while these are different structures with
their own motions, the effect is the same.
Cilia and flagella generate thrust, which
keeps the organism moving.
So protists have evolved these various appendages
that allow them to move in a viscous environment.
And that’s because movement is essential,
whether it’s within a confined area or freely
through space.
It takes hunters to their prey, and it takes
prey away from their hunters.
So for microbes, the syrupy world around them
is actually quite important, and it’s one
scientists are working to understand better.
They’ve studied how these didinium chase
their prey in changing temperatures and viscosity.
They’ve found that increasing the viscosity
of a rotifer’s surroundings slowed its population
growth.
And they’ve tested how viscosity affects
bacterial movement too.
These responses are important for understanding
not only the individual lives of microbes
and the ecosystems they live in.
They’re important for understanding our
own bodies because to many microbes, we are
just another strange geographic feature to
live in.
We’re a living bag of fluids that bacteria
often find their way into.
And how they navigate our body deeply impacts
our health.
Spirochetes, for example, cause Lyme disease
and syphilis.
But to do that, they have to get through blood
and other fluids, which they do in this erratic,
corkscrew motion.
The bacteria is generating thrust with flagella
(though it’s important to note that bacterial
flagella are a completely distinct thing from
the eukaryotic flagella we mentioned earlier).
And spirochetes use their flagella in a way
that’s weird even for bacteria.
They keep their flagella inside them, sandwiched
between their membranes.
And as the flagella rotate internally, they
drive the entire spirochete to rotate and move.
This mechanism doesn’t just move the spirochete,
it also helps them dig deeper into the dense
bits inside us that are more difficult for
other bacteria to penetrate.
And that’s just one example of how a life
in syrup impacts us.
Sometimes the syrup is water, and sometimes
it’s you.
But for microbes, it’s just home.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
Do you have trouble finding time to sit down
and read all of the books that are stacked
in your to-be-read pile either in your nightstand
or just in your head.
Well, Blinkist is here to not only save your
nightstand, but also to help you develop yourself
and learn new things.
Blinkist highlights the most important insights
and need-to-know information from nonfiction
books and condenses them down so that you
can either read or listen to them in just
15 minutes.
And if you’re looking to learn even more
about the microcosmos, you can do so by checking
out books like “The Tangled Tree” by David
Quammen or “I Contain Multitudes” by Ed
Yong, which are both available on Blinkist.
Whether you’re interested in science, history,
self-help, or business, Blinkist has something
for you in the 3,000-plus titles in its library.
So even if you don’t have the time for all
the books you want to read, you can still
find the time to learn new things.
Blinkist has more than 12 million users, and
if you’re one of the first 100 people to
sign up today at Blinkist.com/microcosmos,
you can get free unlimited access for 7 days
and you’ll also get 25% off if you decide
to get a full membership.
Thank you so much to all of the people whose
names are on the screen right now.
These are our Patreon patrons.
Without them we could not make Journey to
the Microcosmos.
So, if you like what you see, these are the
folks to thank.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes James Weiss, check out Jam & Germs
on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.